hey guys I'm gonna answer a question can I eat
these vegetables on a ketogenic diet well let's
go ahead and talk about this because there's
a lot of confusion so we're gonna talk about
like the beets the carrots the peas the tomatoes
and I'm gonna throw in potato corn art artichoke
too because they are they're kind of fall in
that category so if we look at beets beets are
really high in potassium I'm talking like 442
milligrams per cup so all of these are based on
one cup and then the carbs are 13 grams and the
sugar is 9 grams so between the carbs and the
sugar the sugar is the most important thing to
look at because you want to keep the sugar down
really really really low so if something has
a higher carbohydrate it might break down the
sugar very very slow if the fiber is high versus
high sugar it breaks down and sugar really really
fast regardless of how much fiber but fiber does
buffer it so okay so the beet has about 9 grams of
sugar it's pretty high protein is 2.2 but look at
this fiber is 3.8 so it has a good amount of fiber
which will tend to buffer that so the question
is should you eat beets if you're trying to get
in ketosis probably not a good idea however if
you're happy with your weight like myself go
ahead and start eating the beets because they
have a lot of good benefits for the liver for
nutrition good for detox of the gall bladder that
type of thing so generally though if you're trying
to get in ketosis probably not a good idea to eat
beets okay the carrot 195 milligrams of potassium
again potassium is necessary to help lower insulin
so we want that very high look at this six grams
of carbs that's pretty low compared to a beet
it's like half sugars are 2.9 grams so that is
very very low compared to a beet protein not a lot
of protein half the fiber so I would say carrots
would be okay to consume Anna ketogenic diet I
don't think you're gonna have a hard a problem
with that because of these two are very very
low and plus all I mean just have some fiver so
I wouldn't try to avoid carrots okay all right
the P peas snap peas or dis regular piece 354
milligrams of potassium it's pretty high 21 grams
of carbs is pretty high 8 grams of sugar pretty
high look how much protein eight grams of protein
wow that's interesting that's probably ever hear a
pea protein before well that's why you don't hear
of karat protein do you and then we got 7 grams
of fiber that's pretty high so peas I probably
would stay away from peds simply because of the
higher level of sugar okay all right tomatoes 292
milligrams of potassium four point eight grams of
carbs it's that's pretty low that's actually lower
than carrots three point two grams of sugar that's
still pretty low I mean it's like just a little
bit more than carrots so tomatoes are probably a
better thing to consume so far than any eat other
things we talked about okay so it's kind of tied
with Cara but tomato is pretty pretty low and then
we have one point one gram of protein 1.5 grams of
fiber okay not as much fiber as the pea but still
there's a little bit of fiber and they're kind of
similar to a carrot okay so I would say okay
consume tomatoes on a ketogenic diet so so far
our carrot and tomato are okay but not beat in no
not peace now potato 897 milligrams of potassium
that is a tremendous amount and then we got 37
grams of carbs that's a lot of carbs and then
but look at this we got one point seven grams
of actual sugars so it's low but we know this
type of starch does break down into sugar faster
than we'd like it 4.3 grams of protein is pretty
high and look how much fiber 4.7 grams so potato
even though it has potassium this is the culprit
right here there's 37 thing so that's the problem
with this it's the it's way way higher than for
a DIN tomato or a six six carbs okay but it is
low in sugar so if you're trying to appear a child
let's say your kids are younger this would be
potatoes would be good I would do sweet potatoes
and yam red potato make sure they're organic
it's not a bad food but this may slow you down
losing weight okay now corn 476 milligrams of
potassium it's pretty high a hundred and twenty
three grams of carbs so this is why we do not want
to consume corn in addition to all the corners GML
so we don't want to do that and then one gram of
sugar okay well that's good but still it's such a
starch 16 grant I was really surprised that corn
has 16 grams of protein I just find that hard to
believe but that was what the sources said I'm
not sure with the fibrous but I don't know corn
protein I don't know I don't know that doesn't
make sense to me okay artichoke six hundred and
forty four milligrams of potassium so it comes
in second place just behind potato and then we
have carbs two hundred and sixty nine grams oh my
goodness that is it beats all the other vegetables
for the amount of carbs so this is really high in
carbs per cup and look at this 14 grams of sugar
artichoke is the worst thing you can eat on a
ketogenic diet don't eat it now protein 3 3 grams
fiber is 2.4 okay so I'm going to recommend that
you stick with the carrot and tomato and probably
not do these other ones okay all right thank
you for watching I'll see you the next video